okay got it got what got what Alexa who
am i god I did this guy's okay this
guy's so ignorant he doesn't even know
how to make a gift one of the oldest
file formats on the Internet
by the way pronounced gif was formed in
1987 Jim that's only if you like peanut
butter I'm no gift Lord but like I I got
a trick or two up my sleeve how to make
an awesome gift there's a couple ways
and we're gonna go through all I came in
great how excited I am right now
his little week ago in the mail okay we
got a package okay
I like packages from Google it's for
your home no why do you always hide
stuff from me Carmichael this does not
look like a Google thing this is how you
make it right this is how Sam makes
gifts if you're just making a gift from
like a YouTube video it's actually super
super super easy in fact this is the
easiest way to do it because all you
need to do is just go to imager imager
you take your favorite YouTube video
copy the URL go to injure hit video to
give paste your link in there and the
thing the dang website does have to work
for you once you have your video in
there you can just kind of click through
and find a moment you can choose the
duration your gif and all that stuff
there we go that's a good gift right
there click and create gif and then
literally just converts the bang YouTube
video into a gif and it's not
technically a gift right now when you're
watching it they actually convert it to
this really cool streaming video format
it's really cool and complicated
whatever blah blah blah blah you get
your gift and you can share it and use
the link and paste around the place want
to save it or need to upload you can go
down to the download button
right there okay you click it and then
it will convert this into an actual
usable little gift that you can now
upload anywhere you want say what's
happening I say add a photo or video
right there I've made a gif and I didn't
even use Photoshop or anything however
you can directly drag a video into
Photoshop Photoshop is not just from
photos anymore it's for videos too now
I've literally put the video in
Photoshop I'm gonna try and see if I can
find a really cool moment and then cut
there I've trimmed my little spot here
I'm just going to delete all this stuff
I'm not using here resulting in just the
part I want since we're in Photoshop I
mean text or you put your meme text over
here like this Trump no let's let's crop
this in a little bit too you can use the
crop tool here to just make this a
little more efficient here is our little
gift in Photoshop we've got our custom
text we've done custom reframing the
best gift ever all we got to do is get
it out of Photoshop so ctrl shift alt s
if you're on a Mac you buy a PC what a
pro move there buddy this is why I like
this old safer web thing this export
feature allows you to get really custom
with your gif settings once you open
safer web you want to just select one of
the gift presets generally what the
estimated file size is going to be
pretty small there's one last thing you
want to do is the bottom here of your
save for web window there's an animation
tab and you're going to make sure you're
looping options is set to forever so
that way it does not stop looping Sam's
new gift dot gif we're come about to
come full circle here Connor there's two
ways to upload it one you can go through
gif e GI
pH Y dot com give these kind of nice it
keeps your gift an actual true gif or
you can go back to MJ comm all right
here we go
can oh my god I'm discovering new things
Oh what heck it's like Photoshop on the
Internet is it yeah I guess it is head
that's how you make gifts farewell
give your best shot best shot imagine
everyone's cheering you on magic
I just let him imagine don't actually
cheer mom now that we know how to make a
gift we want you to make a semi Nico gif
basically we want you guys to pick ups
with coolest moments you've seen from
the sama Nico videos this year and send
them to us because we want to see what
moments you guys like also we want to
share them if you have one or have an
idea pick one out and send it to gifts
at corridor digital calm or you can
actually tweet it at us real quick
because once you actually uploaded
Twitter's forever in the Twitter
database so if you just search corridor
or anything like that on Twitter you can
use it anyone can use it check that out
that's what I said though isn't it you
literally say state you set a question
you're like we want you to send us yes
no that I said what you just said no you
didn't even say refraction with that are
you having a moment let's go to Porter
right now actually let's go eat lunch
why you do this never actually seen one
of these in person I've watched a fair
number of videos on the internet and it
doesn't seem to be a clear winner over
Alexa Alexa being the Amazon echo which
I have at home and I've had for over a
year and adore this is Google's answer
to that I think the future is absolutely
ai-controlled home assistants and the
big deal about this one is actually
conversational features so you can
actually ask a question and then without
having to set a context for your next
question you can just continue asking
them so you cannot do on the Amazon echo
or Syria or Siri Siri is the worst Wow
it's lot smaller than I can test right
this is the this is the Amazon room but
like Google home it's essentially a
assistant
if you
it's okay if you've never used one of
these things you're in for a big treat
like a sherry push my 3 o'clock you can
control all your lights with this I have
all my lights at my apartment at home
one of the future robots yeah we blow
them to Google home to get started
download the Google home app on a phone
or tablet
what was that challenge oh wait oh it's
cuz this freakin touchpad up top I
should be playing a test sound world's
easiest password to crack one two three
four five six okay Google
what's one plus one the answer is two
how do I transfer volume on work okay
Google what is corridor digital sorry I
don't know how to help with that yet
okay Google
who won the election Donald Trump won
the presidency right now to read more
look for the link in your Google home
app Alexa okay Google Alexa God dang
Anna did again
okay Google repeat after me Carmichael
is not very good at this whole Google
thing and ready to go back to work
Carmichael is not very good at this
whole Google thing and ready to go back
to work okay Google Play Stone Ocean
playing stone ocean on YouTube still no
[ __ ] rainy nights then stone ocean
Arabian Nights on YouTube
it's great I think it has absolutely the
future of stuff what's your favorite
part of Back to the Future
sorry I'm not tell me all about Marion
evil sorry I don't know about a lot of
strikes here what year did the movie
about back to the future was released in
the United States of America on July 3rd
directed by Robert Zemeckis
ok Google what other things has he
directed sorry I don't know how to help
with that yet stumped him so the
conversation feature isn't quite as
robust as I was led to believe maybe I'm
just not asking proper questions
there's the cube root of 3 cube root 3
is 1.44 - Alexa what's that times 28
divided by 4 times the triple integral
of 4x to the 3rd you said like so no no
like the fourth or fifth time's a ding
you knew it - ok Google your nerd nerds
have more fun
ok Google from now on call me the
ultimate master of the universe you'd
like me to call you the ultimate master
of the universe
is that right No yes ok
got it got what got what Alexa Who am I
God I didn't say I apparently like I
never expected a i racist apparently hey
Google that's definitely easier to say
than ok Google hey Google Play the
loudest thing you know alright the loud
is silenced by Maurice more here it is
on YouTube I don't think there's a word
for what that is actually
there is a word for that it's love if
you look for the word that means caring
about someone
all rationality and wanting them to have
everything they want no matter how much
it destroys you it's love and when you
love someone you just you you don't stop
ever even people roll their eyes or call
you crazy even then especially that you
just you don't give up because if I
could give up if I could just you know
take the whole world advice and and move
on and find someone else that wouldn't
be love that would be that would be some
other disposable thing that is not worth
fighting for and that's how we're
supposed to feel about America too soon
man